prova prova propria propria pratella
qualcuno vuole un po di estate people of
internet 5 milioni e passa mamma mia
avete presente i giochi tipo the crooked
man the witch house and honey ecco hanno
fatto questo gioco qualche sembra molto
caso a un incrocio tra the witch house e
non so che cos'altro però è molto carino
e dello stesso genere ovviamente sempre
rpg e iniziamo let's go
mi sembra molto figo già il menù è figo
non so di che parla e in inglese quindi
vi devo tradurre quindi ci penso io a
tradurle ragazzi erano molto che non
giocavo un rpg fatto veramente bene cavo
lavora che figata
siamo davanti a una chiesa non so non mi
hanno detto in età preistorica siamo
però bene bene bene guarda che
finalmente ha deciso di unirsi a noi
salve mi sono svegliato adesso come
quando torno un sacco mia madre non so
se sono molto meno dove sono sei al
general hospital
non preoccuparti chiamare un dottore
così potrà curarti non so tradurre la
perfezione ma ok dottore alla mia la mia
testa non riesco a eccessi problemi di
attoriali io proprio ming è brutto era
meglio non non vederlo il culo la solo
che questo successo perché sono qua
l'ispettore da balda volt della polizia
ti spiegherà a sta arrivando ve ne e gia
quattro perfetto siamo riusciti a red
dead redemption mister fossette
picchiamo fosse per favore ispettore mi
chiami jules e solista di poesia marcel
da volte sono incaricato nel tuo caso
ti ricordi qualcosa di quello che è
successo qualsiasi dettaglio del perché
sei qua mi dispiace non ricordo niente
secondo gli investigatori tua sorella i
tuoi amici siete stati trovati nel
isolotto di new ville prima che io posso
darti altre informazioni ho bisogno che
ci pensi che cosa ricordi qualsiasi
dettaglio può essere d'aiuto a si sta
ricordando what
adesso parte la parta lo ho capito e uno
c'è lui lui è sopravvissuto a questa
cosa è il sogno sta raccontando e noi
giochiamo la parte in cui è successo
quello che è successo quello che succede
che non sappiamo che cos'è bello questa
non è una chiesa
questo è poco ma sicuro è una casa
abbandonata di quella tipo l'esorcista o
tipo de congiu ring l'evocazione
sembrato quello si apre da sola non era
la sola c'è gente indiana jones e morgan
che perdita di tempo lo sono anche
perché siamo venuti fino qua
andiamo dai non sempre un po curioso
curioso si è ora dispiaciuto non credo a
tutte le cose senza senso che spara tua
sorella tristan se ne stanno andando tra
l'altro ok o eccomi questo sono io è
infelice aspetta che lo stai facendo
felice felice felice come si dice ma
porca vacca che kakà cosa è successo
si parte cosa è successo
e buio maledizione già notte a dove
essere stato bloccato per un po felice
devo trovarla non c'era una lampada
alchemica sulla barca quindi devo andare
devo andare al porto quindi esco vado
no non devo uscire andare porto ok sto
uscendo salve signor gatto ci facevi
l'insieme ogni tanto rory che cos'è
errori si chiama come me il gatto vabbè
non posso vedere non vedevi amici
nessuna parte dove siano andati a v e mi
servirebbe la
la lampada ad olio o alchemica lamp la
lampada alchemica vabbè permesso amici
dove sono ben altro domanda numero 1
cosa ci facciamo su quest'isola domanda
numero 2 dove sono i miei amici domanda
numero 3 perché si è fatto un bong
invece di venire qua che sta questo
rumore ma sono io che mi stanco sto male
nokia ma sto gioco ha fatto bene non ho
mai visto nelle pc così ben dettagliato
secondo in questa casa abbandonata
perché siamo dei bravi ragazzi che vanno
a fare cose che non devono fare il gatto
è sparito permesso ok ciò la lampada
come si usa fantasmi ho visto fantasmi
qua è molto allegro questo posto meno
male
una scultura religiosa fatta di pietra è
veramente molto danneggiata un buco
incavato nel piedistallo che ci sono dei
quadri aspetta c'è qualcosa a lo posso
tipo è un quadro ma si può staccare
possono staccare dei pezzi ave tanto non
posso farlo finché non trova oggetti
sento casinò di qua chiede al morra che
sbatte la porta vabbè lasciamo perdere
la porta 6 braccia e un qualcosa nel
mezzo è un bottone un piedistallo aver
schiacciato
ho attivato qualcosa non so cosa bene ne
sono quanti stanze ci son east opposto
enorme scritto la parola greco appare
che devo parlare in greco è stata aperta
questa roba qua c'è un emblema sono due
bottoni cosa fanno
non lo so cosa fanno e che ne so io
differenza età ed a differenza di età di
altezza
che me frega a me ha forse per la
soluzione dei tasti di prima parti che
fa i su su su su giù giù no su 4 su 10 e
l'altro giorno hai visto ha funzionato
un serio ma no era giusto il quadro ho
fatto su su su gesù praticamente
fighissima è bene cosa è successo
hanno preso mentre va beh nava africana
stato amica sono mi sono stupito di me
stesso
bene meno male che non ho rotto nulla
erano valsi comunque sono un genio non
sono sorpreso di me stesso tantissimo
però fatto sono mai successo la uso
intelligente buongiorno ma lei c'era
anche prima non l'avevo vista felice e
lei felice non mi sembra tanto felice
stai dormendo per svegliarle portarla
fuori da questo posto va bene brava
bella felice che svegliandosi si sveglia
a posti jules sei tu dove sei stato mi
sono preoccupata uscire acqua prima che
è uscire
no non voglio uscire di vignette siamo
diventati vie di vieta il nome del gioco
d'azione diventati amici voglio stare
con lei per sempre di vignette d'oggi si
re palo magari vi viet si dice di rienzo
non so se sto pronunciando giusto stai
parlando a una bambola the witch house
ragazzi sto gioco e cosa no anche tu
come ti permetti è una bambola felice mi
dispiace non non ti arrabbiare
lei mi capisce lei e gentile mica come i
tuoi amici
lei crede in me è una bambola abbiamo
preso un te l'ho preparato io ecco jules
ne ho conservato un po perché se in
quella roba ci metti la bamba perché a
quanto pare ce la metti io non la prendo
pro grazie molto gentili se non lo bevi
la farei stare male non mi fa scegliere
se l'avevo notte ok a niente ha bevuto
lo stesso bambino
insomma forse witch house stai facendo
se beve di cose strane morivi dopo un
secondo papà prof
era esattamente quello che pensavo bene
proprio come the witch house schiatti e
non ci puoi fare niente
mi sono addormentato mai accettare i the
dalí sconosciuti anzi soprattutto dagli
dai conosciuti e stato stupido giu
infatti se avessi giocato a the witch
house te ne saresti accorto comunque
l'emblema va messo nella statua con la
contro dall'inizio let's get trend o un
orologio a posso muovere l'orologio è un
altro enigma devo trovare un qualche
cosa per risolversi nigma non ho capito
bene cosa è fighissimo questo gioco
perché la casa è grossa ma è solo
protetta da degli enigmi e figli si è
bellissimo mi piace sta piacendo
tantissimo giuro su dio ed è difficile
trovare un rpg horror che mi piaccia
così tanto ultimamente veramente
difficile la parola maestro quindi devo
risolvere la roba da s infila azione di
emblema in 3 2 1 dopo come selezionarlo
ok grazie
la chiave maestro ecco appunto come non
detto
ma qua sporadico posso andare perché chi
è quel lurido che urla eccolo è un gatto
chi farebbe una cosa così orribile a un
povero animale aspettava e il gatto di
gatto dalle balene felice hai ammazzato
un gatto se hai dei problemi secondo me
felice questo non è un gioco
la classica battuta di quando giochi è
un videogioco e dicono questo non è un
gioco
ahia dobbiamo andarcene che cosa che non
va con te porca vacca felice che cosa ti
è successo felice fai un po di make up
bugiardo tu vuoi chiudermi in
quell'orribile posto ancora quale posto
zia sbraccia e calma nei paesini gli
spaventi e lo stesso intanto sembra
impazzita felice non venire vicino
fermati
mi piace che le scritte marca vacca che
ansia le scritte aprì a parte le scritte
quelle ansiolitiche le scrivono tutte le
movimentate stata solari fa impazzire
io mi sa che devo evitarla ma mi segue
fino qua ho fatto il giro fatto giro vai
veloce veloce lì sopra di sopra beh non
dovrebbe seguire in più in teoria e tipo
aoni è un mix di tutti gli rpg messi
insieme è fighissimo
e veramente fighissimo giuro ho questa
si apre a sono stato bravo
la prima volta non solo morto in aoni
sono morto sempre la prima volta anche
quando sapevo come andava a finire
va bene non ho mai ma perché vai
dettagliatissimo presso un rpg fatto
veramente bene sono proprio contento
let's golf faccia niente sia stato
prodotto va la partita si era abbassato
attraverso che è burgio del culo quindi
mi cerca per tutta la casa la riuscita a
uscire mentre rientrava ho avuto
purissimo e quindi è lì quindi andiamo
avanti velocemente per cortesia alla
porta maestro st18i non questa
tranquilla in nessun posto ne apre
questa i flop
quindi ragazzi questa è la vietta il
primo episodio e figgis e veramente
fatto bene veramente belli non vedo la
rifinirlo per essere uno dei primi a
portarlo perché ho visto molto in giro
comunque molto carino se proprio vi sia
piaciuto continueremo nel prossimo
episodio cose i ragazzi del viso è
piaciuto fare un commento
è un mi piace anche ai vari social che
comitato descrizione sede essere
presidiate e noi ci vediamo ora un
prossimo visto da ragazzi
[Musica]